covetous is more outgoing than I am
certainly I am more laid-back
I can say I can say things that he can't
so to speak so you find it easier to let
yourself go just say sorry complicated
yes that's true something that's true
I don't do outrageous I do his
outrageous things that's true Jim Anson
and Kermit the Frog in a 1979 interview
with Morley Safer of 60 minutes this
morning thanks to a donation from the
late Muppet masters family and help from
his fans some of Henson's greatest
creations have a new home at the Museum
of the moving image here in New York
City before the Muppet Show and Sesame
Street changed American culture Jim
Henson was a young puppeteer an
experimental filmmaker now the full
story of his nearly 40-year career is
being told at a new exhibit in the
Museum of the moving image we really
wanted to tell term a comprehensive
story about Jim Henson's creative
journey when he started working in
television as a teenager really in 1955
just the sort of constant reaching for
something new the permanent exhibit
unveiled this week features more than
300 artifacts many of them donated by
Henson's family including 47 puppets
ranging from Kermit the Frog and a
full-size big bird to Yorick a puppet
used by Henson just a few times on a
1950s TV show
[Music]
visitors can also use an interactive
display to understand what it's like to
control them up in long time Muppets
fans also played an important role in
building the exhibit as more than 2,000
people contributed to a Kickstarter fund
to make it all possible
there's no community that I know of that
is that has stronger feelings in me than
the community out there that our Jim
Henson fans they feel such a connection
to his work was really amazing
experience to sort of feel all that
commitment from that fan base and have
them be part of it okay I'm in I want to
go it is fantastic I mean look at that
I'm been a Miss Piggy fan since I was a
kid I still am my favorite Muppet is
Grover